was wäre wenn die geschichte eine andere
wendung genommen hätte wie wäre unser
leben davon betroffen in romanen und
filmen wird dieser gedanke gern
durchgespielt
was wäre wenn hitler den zweiten
weltkrieg gewonnen hätte und amerika von
den nazis regiert würde das fragt eine
neue us-serie der reichsadler als
leitmotiv der us kultur nennen
kassel zeichnet ein bedrückendes
alternativszenario auf
literaturwissenschaftlerin christine
lötscher ortet eine große lust am sog
den pessimistische zukunftsszenarien
sogenannte dystopien aus 7
doch sie sollen aufrütteln und dass ich
für die reben einer spannend dass sie
sich dann fragt das dass sich die
geschichte frage dabei die wenn er hat
blase oder zuschauer sich fragen wo hat
denn dort liegt auch verbindungen zu
dazu die realität der meinen der hai
kassel basiert auf dem roman von philip
kritik von 1962
amerikas wertesystem wird von den
deutschen bestimmt die regierung mit
hätte
ungehemmter rassismus gehört zum
politischen konzept traditionell sind es
vier jahren geschichte geworden
vor dem was kann passieren so
weitermacht wie bis jetzt also dass man
das dass die geschichten eigentlich
waren pendant awards gesellschaft
erkannt und planen und dir übertrieben
bis einen punkt wo man sieht also zur
kenntlichkeit in stelle eigentlich dass
finanzminister gewahrt
damit macht sie die cobra und sich vor
allem kann aufwerten
wo jetzt vielleicht in vorangestellt
sind auch in den kinofilmen der hunger
games wird so eine beklemmende
zukunftsvision gezeichnet ein
totalitärer staat der keine persönlichen
freiheiten toleriert
dabei liegt uns das individuelle glück
doch so am herzen wir beschwören es
sehnsüchtig herauf mit der frage was
wäre wenn
während wir glücklicher hätten wir
irgendwo in der vergangenheit eine
andere abzweigen genommen mit diesem
motiv spielt auch die neue verfilmung
des martin suter romans die dunkle seite
des mondes ein erfolgreicher
wirtschaftsanwalt will aus seinem leben
auf der überholspur ausbrechen
ein drogentrip mit halluzinogenen pilzen
soll ihm den entscheidenden kick geben
ich weiß die dinger seht ihr nicht
verschrumpelt aus weil ich schmecke auch
richtig heiße aber die für ricoh ist
mein weg
wir sind im recht unfair ihre person und
irgendwie immer was für das temperament
das man hat was für die trasse dass man
etwas für ihre herkunft das kommt sehr
sehr bedingt nummer andere vertrauen mit
sie als nur das frisch und empfehle ich
sich optimieren und ich glaube das ist
ganz tolle ausgangslage zum
geschichtenerzählen
doch die sache geht gründlich schief für
den anwalt
anstelle eines neuen seiner füllten
lebens folgt der nackte horror
dabei ist der gedanke doch so schön sich
vorzustellen dass wir unser schicksal
optimieren könnten im film oder buch
aber da enden diese versuche fast immer
in der musik
der hat jetzt das probiert dauerhaft fuß
es schwingt in diesen geschichten wohl
immer auch ein appell an die vernunft
mit
nur weil etwas anders ist ist es nicht
automatisch besser